revolving doors always open always
closed so why do we have them
meet theophilus van canel a curmudgeon
and a scrooge of sorts humboldt
he hated lots of things none more so
than chivalry especially opening doors
for women he also hated and i mean hated
that awkward dance we've all experienced
after you no after you no no i insist
after you after you van canel created a
way to eliminate his social phobia by
drawing inspiration from a pre-existing
german to luftsug translation door
without draft of air in 1888 van canel
received a patent for a storm door
structure aka the revolving door in 1899
the first one was installed at rectors a
restaurant in new york city it was
revolutionary not only did it eliminate
forced social interaction revolving
doors kept dust rain sleet snow and
noise from entering buildings and kept
the heat and air conditioning inside
seems great energy efficient but there's
a catch
no one uses them in 2006 an mit study
found only 20 to 30 percent of people
were using the revolving doors so why
don't we use them probably because
swinging doors are just easier but mr
van canel we salute you in your
anti-social ways
you